0.17 er ist einfach da oben alles klar
und fügt noch weiter ok oh s s kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
projekt am 9 format dass ich mir
ausgedacht habe das heißt hacker show
ich habe es ja schon mal im video
angesprochen hier geht es darum dass ihr
material von hackern zusendet ich mir
das anschaue das kommentiere und ihr am
ende der runde dann entscheiden dürfte
tweer jetzt der beste krasseste hacker
whatever war also es ganz eure
entscheidung ich mache das wie es gesagt
habe als ich euch darum gebeten hat mir
was einzuschicken das heißt die person
deren video material verwendet wird die
wird namentlich erwähnt ich blende
wahrscheinlich den namen an der ecke ein
bisschen davor vor
vor dem klever spiel ganz wichtig ist es
dass ihr unbedingt euer feedback in die
kommentare schreibt weil das ist die
erste folge des neuen projektes sei es
steht alles noch in den kinderschuhen
zieht noch tausend dinge die man
verbessern kann wenn euch welche
einfallen
im laufe des videos am anfang aber er
schreibt unbedingt direkt in die
kommentare rein ich habe mir die
besonders durch lesen grund alles
aufnehmen host an konstruktiven fällt so
drin steht übrigens die facebook wird
noch keiner gemacht ich habe nur gerade
im hintergrund ein video von mir das ist
von gestern dem 26
im video habe ich ja wie gespielt mir
nichts dir nichts und einem tablett spaß
und mir dachte bisschen komisch wieder
so läuft
aber schaut euch das mal nicht wahr so
blind schaut euch ich sage nicht versagt
gemacht da seht einfach selbst
seht euch einfach selbst an was dieser
typ gemacht hat und ich habe es nicht
gesehen ich so ja vielleicht hätte
vielleicht aber guck mal so ich erzähle
einfach sowas vor mich hin
es ist jetzt mittlerweile fertig nach
zwei monaten oder so schon gleich wird
er kommen lauf da durch die gegend und
jetzt achtet mal auf diesen bereich hier
ich hab ich mal gemietet und jetzt schon
acht mal da hin
alles klar er fliegt die wand hoch und
ich schaue noch hin
ich schaue doch hin und guckt mal was
ich sage in dem moment hier ist mein
neues intro wen interessiert das neue
intro der typ ist gerade die wand hoch
geflogen alter dann habe ich mein neues
intro gezeigt alles klar und der typ
dieser hacker denn sie an soja vockel
ich bin zwar schon die wand hoch
geflogen
dann kann hier nochmal richtig aufdrehen
und erhöht noch heraus das sieht so
lustig aus und achtet mal darauf ich
merke nichts
wie gefällt euch gerne mal die
kommentare und gerne auch noch feedback
falls ihr falls ich irgendwann einfach
dass man spontan dann ändert sich das
gibt sich habt ihr das gesehen
achtet mal auf diesen bereich erachtet
mal hier drauf sogleich macht einfach so
diks der wave vom heaven passt doch da
kommt er einfach runter gute ich es an
er fliegt so krass ich will ich schon
voll dahin es so krass alter sohn an
dieser stelle kämpfe ich dann gegen ihn
der konsti com herr bock hat der hector
und er hat offensichtlich nur noch berg
jetzt fast auf die dummheit geht weiter
die blindheit geht weiter achtet mal
hier drauf all diese stelle was war das
viel geld die wand hoch und ich merke
nichts aber junge leute das war's so
weit von meinem video ist soll aber eine
projekt nicht meine videos gehen sondern
die videos die e mail zu schicken
deswegen legen wir jetzt direkt los mit
der ersten sendung ich werde mir die
blind anschaulicher wieder vor noch
nicht angesehen noch nicht gesichtet und
das heißt ich reagiere genau im ersten
moment so dazu wie ihr also schon okay
leute die erste einsendung von vinci und
wir schauen einfach mal rein
und er kann er für mich gerettet werden
hat er was geschrieben
ob peter der easyjet geschrieben
ja das ist der schritt ist es wirklich
dieser typ achtet mal drauf er heißt wie
sieht man dass hier mit ex rallye so
heißt komme mal kurz vor
jetzt achtet auf den jet bis xl die
einfach ist wunderbar dieser typ ist
genial
also leute nicht dass ich hecken
unterstütze aber das ist einfach dreist
das ist richtig fakten kreis kommen hier
wir schauen uns das noch mal an dass
sogar das muss man sich einfach noch mal
anschauen so geil
er läuft einfach mit dem bogen nicht die
gegend trifft jeden fall schlägt man mit
dem schwert dann schießt er wieder mit
dem bogen der von maschinengewehr und
ein schwert bis elo gesperrt diesen
bogen okay der eine ecke auf jeden fall
das recht mal lieber da vinci
ja das war die erste einzelspringen es
mal zur zweiten und ich mache die
festung auf jeden fall mal kleine sohn
ist gerade ihm aufgefallen dass das ist
mir nicht aufgefallen ist aufgefallen
dass die face com auf viel zu weit oben
war also man hat über meinen kopf
personen mit der band gesehen
ich hoffe die wand will ich soweit
gefallen ich habe zuerst mal raus
genommen zugunsten meiner haare und im
unteren teil ihr meinen körper aber es
ist jetzt mal drin
das zweite video von online-games 5 und
es sieht aus als hätte der musik im
hintergrund wird seine minuten wir mal
hat wahrscheinlich auf seinen ton
gemietet dann schauen wir mal an
natürlich fliegt er für eine luftraum
leute das ist kurz mal das ist nicht
gestorben also diese typ lebt einfach es
ist nicht so wie games runde und er
fliegt einfach oben chillig in der luft
bundesaufgabe hd scheinbar weil er dem
report funktion benutzen will sich kuka
alle stehen da unten und schien so
miteinander gucken einfach nur hoch
kommt zeigt dir nochmal ja da oben ist
und hier achtet auf diesem bild
dispenser youtube übrigens komme admins
aller server wie das gerade sehen
ihr könnt natürlich die leute immer noch
wann falls sie noch nicht gebannt wurden
dafür dass ich eine gute sache möchte zu
bannen
genau deswegen mache ich mache das dann
mit euch gebannt werden nicht zu
unterhaltungszwecken so jetzt achten wir
auf diesen dispenser youtube achtung und
32 was auch wahrscheinlich hat er sich
gedacht okay ich habe keine chance in
dieser runde system ist es teams wie
games und die gehen mir zu viel hitze
oder lachte sie also alles klar
ich werde jetzt mal das flugzeug
richtung nottwil 321 punkte da oben
guckt euch das an
das eine gehälter ich darf die hacker
echte viel loben aber das ist einfach so
dreist und ich finde irgendwie witzig
aber es ist sehr unverantwortlich von
ihm dorthin zu fliegen
warum hat er gesagt baum hatte dieses
getan
ich verurteile hecken amüsiere mich
nicht weil diese videos anzusehen
okay das war's mit einwendungen 32 die
erste als video war von mir also ist das
ein sendung zwei wir springen direkt zu
einsendungen drei einsendungen drei
kommt von bei johannes und bei johannes
sagt er hat ein lächerliches hacker team
auf timo ja im tourismus zu gesehen ich
will sagen wir schon mal rein
okay gut aus
das alte schlägt ihn nicht mag ja
scheinbar ein mac wieder um rechts sehen
updates bereit zur installation gut das
können wir jetzt nämlich nicht einfach
aber jetzt sind sie da oben er wie kann
ich kann mir so schnell da hoch
muttertag war ein katrin
doch
was ausgesät hat es gesehen
auf einmal sagt er fliegt auf einmal der
hoch erachtet mal hat man hier drauf da
ist noch da unten
das video ist bei 0 14 so gezogener play
so 00 14 immer noch 0 15
man sieht kurz es auf einmal der luft
und jetzt 0 17 er ist einfach da oben
alles klar
und noch weiter ok
was er hat ihm gar die hier leben nicht
mal angeschaut hat ihn geschlagen okay
aber es klappt wagt erfolgen wie kassel
zurück das thema drauf er kann komplett
immer fliegen weil der internet zu
schlecht ist
jetzt kommt andere unter okay da ist auf
jeden fall auch der neiße hacks der
andere kollege aber dennoch weg zu alter
tatsächlich an getötet es gibt ja nicht
aber ich der andere noch am leben
ja da ist in der ecke wasser auf und
jetzt was machst du da ist ok er schon
die hacks aus einem brennt tatsächlich
lässt sich okay jetzt anfangen zu
fliegen
auf jeden fall zu fliegen alter der
krieg tatsächlich auch noch pech als er
nur noch bäcker daraus gemacht was er
gerade eben drin hatte danach lassen
wenn es aus jetzt erwartet sich ok und
jetzt andere ok existiert verletzt jetzt
kommt daran ja okay ich auch mal diese
distanz jetzt an
er kann nichts machen aber es ist
wirklich einfach dreist und jetzt schon
dahinschweben der pflicht zu dir
versuchte fliegt gleich erhebt ab was
auf der wii speak exakt alles klar
ok also dieser junge hat wirklich
wirklich alle hacks aktiviert die man
aktivieren kann nordbeck flyers fehlt
ein sprinter kortner fakt alter so leute
das war's auch schon von der allerersten
folge der hacker show wenn ihr mehr
einsendungen haben wolltest in die
kommentare schreibt mal rein was so eure
ideale anzahl für einsendung wer durch
51 uhr einpacken oder 7 oder 10
und ganz ganz ganz wichtig wer das
gesehen habt und noch ein sendung habt
schickt unbedingt alle materialien die
ihr habt an mich schreibt bei youtube
den link oft als nicht gelistetes video
da rein und unbedingt ganz ganz wichtig
die erlaubnis mehr geben das
videomaterial zu benutzen uns kann ich
leider nicht benutzen und auch nicht in
dem video erwähnen wenn ihr das beachtet
dann schickt fleißig alle hacker
materialien ein die ihr habt mit ein
bisschen glück kommt ins video und
werden erwähnt und wir haben alle
zusammen mit ordentlichen lacher
in diesem sinne leute hereinlassen
leichter und guten flug